ten years they have one visit
and you call that family
and you sit right there right there and
you told me you would give me every
opportunity to create the future I want
and I meant no you didn't you lied and
you cleared my wings from the start and
you let me think my dad abandoned me
and now I can't trust none of y'all hey
well well please
wait okay
you'll have to leave
look I was in there
nasty Hillary
I love you
but I gotta do what's right for me
well
well
I I understand but if you could make
this happen as soon as possible we'd
appreciate it oh what did they say
they said that if jeffy's the only one
who set up the car GPS then he's the
only one who controls
our
covering
I spent three hours unless we report
will is missing we're stuck at the
moment
dad
[Music]
how come Jeffrey isn't returning our
calls
I have no idea
hopefully we'll hear back soon
oh where are you going I'm going to find
will
it's fine you should answer it maybe
she's heard something
dad we know about Jeffrey
hey if I what happened with Lou is he
still there
no he left okay then what happened I
heard from will I keep calling and
texting he won't answer that's because
it didn't go so well between
very bad
that's when we ran out of here with
tears and his eyes we're trying to find
him now find him now
what you mean he left and you just you
just let him go
I should have told that boy the truth
myself because
I had been there for him this never
would have happened
bye what have I done babe
what have I done
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing here Carlton hey um I
need you to help me find well he's gone
missing missing yeah he left a few hours
ago and no one knows where he is he
stood me up today Carlton look after he
told me he loved me he stood me up his
dad showed up at the house today
oh my gosh yeah and it was badly so it
was so bad it's like everything that he
was afraid of about his father is true
but it's somehow worse because my
parents have been lying to him this
whole time
I think it was all too much for him to
take and so he ran away and
and I don't know if he's gonna come back
so you have to help me find him please
he never turned his back on me
and I needed that
and I need that now